from embodying country music icon Johnny
Cash and walked the line down to his
distinctive singing voice to the vicious
sadism of the emperor in Khiladi ater
Joaquin Phoenix has proven that his
range is virtually unmatched but his
rise to fame was neither assured nor
straightforward born Joaquin Raphael
bottom on October 28 1974 in Puerto Rico
Phoenix had no manic early years as his
parents were members of the children of
God Christian missionary group now
classified as a cult because of their
involvement in that organization the
bottoms travelled all over South and
Central America until the Colts
increasingly sinister practices
including alleged sexual abuse and
incest began to disenchant Joaquin
parents after escaping children of God
and returning to the US with her five
kids in tow the bottoms eventually
settled in Los Angeles they changed
their last name from bottom to Phoenix
and Joaquin also decided to go by the
first name leap so he could better match
with his brother River and their sisters
summer rain and liberty the Phoenix kids
played music on the streets for rent
money until their mom Arlen aka farts
got a job as a secretary to an NBC
casting agent through her networking a
well-known casting agent was won over by
the family's talent and shepherded them
into the bright lights of Hollywood
Joaquin Phoenix went by his chosen name
leap for the first few years of his
acting career but it was actually his
brother who snagged the first screen
role in the television series Seven
Brides for Seven Brothers River quickly
brought his family along while Keane had
his first TV role on that show too
immediately followed by a string of
small roles on TV
eze river star began to rise in movies
with his breakout and stand by me
Joaquin also landed juicy lead roles in
Space Camp in 1986 and Russkies in 1987
Joaquin's first truly big break wouldn't
come until 1989 with the Steve Martin
family dramedy parenthood as troubled
youngster Gary a boy struggling with his
father's abandonment of his family the
film was a hit and Phoenix was nominated
for a Young Artist Award for Best
leading young actor for this nuanced and
heartbreaking performance
but just as Joaquin was set to follow in
his brother's successful footsteps
another tragedy hit his family that
prevented him from acting for almost two
years on Halloween night in 1993
Joaquin Phoenix was a Hollywood
nightclub the Viper Room when his
brother River overdosed on a cocktail of
drugs Joaquin was the one who called 911
to rein tried to resuscitate River using
CPR River later died at the hospital a
trauma that impacted Joaquin and the
Phoenix family immeasurably Joaquin was
only 19 his brother had recently turned
23
Joaquin Phoenix was so devastated by his
brother's sudden death that he didn't
act for almost two years
by this time Joaquin's parents had split
up and his father John had moved back to
South America while Joaquin's mom and
sisters retreated to their family
property in Florida and the safety of
their connection and privacy to mourn
and heal Joaquin went to live and travel
with his father instead
Joaquin Phoenix was hit extremely hard
losing his brother River but when he
came back to acting he did so with a
vengeance he decided to return to his
given name Joaquin instead of leap scene
for the first time in the credits of Gus
Van Sant's critically acclaimed film to
die for which kick-started a fierce new
chapter of Phoenix's career in 1995 take
adventures after the success of to die
poor Phoenix went on to work with Oliver
Stone on u-turn then went on to the
romantic drama inventing the Abbott's
and the thrillers play pigeons and
8-millimeter but it wasn't until Ridley
Scott's gladiator that Phoenix's talents
brought him his first Oscar nomination
for his layered performance as Emperor
Commodus by the time he worked with M
night Shyamalan on signs and the village
Phoenix had become a full-fledged movie
star while Joaquin Phoenix's earlier
roles were each marked with singular
iterations of Phoenix's profound
emotional depth he took things to a new
level with his method acting and walked
the line in 2005 embody and Johnny Cash
down to a singing voice and earning a
Grammy as well as a Golden Globe for his
tremendous work diving deep emotionally
and physically to embody Johnny Cash and
the addictions that shaped his life and
career would also come with a dark side
for Joaquin Phoenix after filming for
walked the line rapped he checked
himself into rehab for a brief stint
Phoenix had never been more than a
social drinker before walked the line
and had
his alcohol consumption significantly to
better understand cash as he told London
magazine I was really leaning on alcohol
to feel okay that's really what was
during this difficult time Phoenix also
had a terrifying brush with death when
his brakes failed and his car crashed
amazingly he was rescued by documentary
filmmaker Verner Herzl and nobody was
badly injured from 2009 to 2010 the
public at large was worried about
Joaquin Phoenix wondering if he was on
drugs or worse when he announced his
retirement from acting to become a
rapper this period was marked with
Phoenix behaving erratically in
interviews and talk shows like his
now-famous David Letterman appearance
all of which would turn out to be an
elaborate piece of performance art
directed by Phoenix's then
brother-in-law Casey Affleck that was
eventually turned into the mockumentary
I'm still here after this odd detour
Phoenix went on to stunned audiences and
critics with his role as Freddie quell
and Paul Thomas Anderson's the master
which our name is third Oscar nomination
he also starred in Spike Jones is
strangely poignant tech oriented dramedy
her as a lonely man who falls in love
with his computer operating system the
name just one standout role he's had in
his post performance our ears bride in a
way of a critical acclaim for his
performance in the comics inspired 2019
drama Joker
Joaquin Phoenix received the Toronto
International Film Festival tribute
actor award alongside Meryl Streep the
award recognizes decades of cinematic
excellence and during his acceptance
speech Joaquin made rare and emotional
comments about his late brother River
saying when I was 15 or 16 my brother
river came home from work and he had a
VHS copy of a movie called raging bolt
and he sat me down and made me watch it
and the next day he woke me up and he
made me watch it again and he said
you're going to start acting again this
is what you're going to do he didn't ask
me he told me and I'm indebted to him
for that because acting has given me
such an incredible life Phoenix also
credited his father John for gifting him
with an exceptional work ethic that
helped get him to this point but also
equipped that it might not have been
fully on display on the Joker set check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]